So I I'm, I'm critiquing your scores here knowing that, you know,
some of these anime I've also scored myself, but I have no idea.
What I said is my list was done in 2014. Holy.
Seven years ago. Yeah. I see. You've given narrative a six compared to bleach.
So would you say that you preferred bleach over,
[inaudible] never dropped a show more times than I have narratives,
like narratives being one of those shows where it's like, I've, I've watched it,
I've read it and watched it like close to the end.
But along that way,
there were so many points throughout an hour narrative where I'm just like, ah,
maybe it's not worth it or you didn't get that with bleach out.
So I did get that. But with bleach once during the Eisenach that's it? Yeah.
I mean, bleeds for me was just like a constant downhill narrative.
Just kind of went up and down. And I, I think back to,
I think back sometimes I think it's not, it was narrative,
a good show when it would hold up to this day.
And I still think some of the best parts narrowed.
So I still like a amazing, yeah, yeah, no again. And that's,
and that's why I probably gave it a six. Right. It's because like,
I completely understand why it is one of the most beloved enemy out there
today. And so like, I saw parts of that, but again, this was,
I didn't grow up with no retard. Like a lot of people did, like, this was again,
another show that this is just another show.
This is just another show in infamy. Right, right, right. Yeah. So again,
I'm not saying that narrative is bad. I'd just like to point that out.
It's not bad, but it's 10 out of 10 for me. Okay.
I'm trying to see you. What else? I feel like I'm getting interrogated.
This isn't in terrorism, interrogation, interrogation. This is like true crime.
We're British. And you know, so this, this hand move,
his hands are off the table saying that he is quite nervous. Sorry. We're not,
we're not like, okay. So what is the lowest one that you've rated on here?
I'm trying to see. I'm trying to see. Oh, it's I think it's pupa.
Oh yeah. Pupa. I get people one. I think I get Balkan to Pico one. Yeah.
One of the biggest thing that surprised me going through your list is okay.
Be honest. Have you completed every animate you've scored on here? Yes. No way.
No way. So many, except for maybe [inaudible]
[inaudible] cause it's still going after 15 minutes was my son.
I honestly think I have finished everything because like I remember one of,
when are we going to get to my list?
One of the reasons why my list seems like a lot emptier is because if I don't
complete a show, I just don't bother putting in my list. Right. Well,
that's why I have like the on-hold section as well. Oh, you got the.
When did you stop updating this man
really worthy anime man for this? What the? You watch so much anime.
You've also read a Tokyo ghoul season one. The same as season two. Right?
Come on. They are, to me to be fair.
I would rate what did I give season one into?
What do you think you gave season one or two?
I think I gave season one and two like seven. Maybe you did. Okay. Yeah.
[inaudible] season two. Maybe like a four. I was going to say it's it's like,
I give it like a, I dunno what I was on about.
I'd give it like a fry Gunnar seven. You stand by that. Yeah. Yeah, really?
Okay. There were a lot of parts about Tragon I really enjoy.
But I think the problem we tried on is that I was a little too overhyped when I
came into it, because I heard so many people being like,
yo try gun is like same levels as like, you know,
buck on a cowboy vivo. It's like, it's like up there with the big,
like classic leagues. I'm like, all right, I'll get into it.
And I watched it and again, it was good, but not to give spoilers,
but the last quarter of Tragon I was like, the is going on. Yeah,
really, really. I thought the last quarter of Tricon was great. It was great.
I enjoyed it, but I was like, what the is going on? I mean, I spent a long time.
I haven't watched it in literally decades now
since I was trying on, Oh, that's the no Tempest as well. You give that a seven.
That is that like, if there was a benchmark for seven out of 10 shows,
it would be [inaudible] I actually,
I can't remember whatever I say now. It's like a isn't it based on the show?
The Shakespeare, I mean, was it basically shut?
Cause I think it was originally very,
very loosely and buy it off a Shakespeare store.
I don't remember which one it was, but I gave,
I gave a points because at the time it was quite creative and useful.
I really liked it.
Like it's one of I put is that sooner and the Tempest in the same category as I
do dark and then black. Right. When I watched, when I watched it,
it was kind of like it, when I think back I was like,
it seems average my memory, but for some,
but for some reason it sticks with me and I always, I always think back,
I always think back to this show. Right? What did you see? What did you see?
God, God, no, I did finish my point.